hello friends i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today i basically
wanted to talk about the ways in which i
think
uh ghost of tsushima is massively
underrated especially coming from the
perspective of
basically thinking about how much
trash talk this game got before it came
out if you go look at
um my gameplay reaction video from the
state of play
it's full of comments calling it um
generic saying it has no innovation
uh saying it just looks like another
ubisoft open world game and i feel like
just considering the amount of criticism
that it got for that
i don't feel like it's getting enough
credit for the subtle things that it
does
that makes it not that if that made
sense um
so i kind of just wanted to take this
opportunity to talk about some of my
i guess favorite things about this game
and staples of an open world that i
really really really like
but i did also want to say that this was
in part inspired by a tweet um
thread by will maiden who was a
avalanche studios who just pointed out
some things that i was like you're right
we aren't
talking about the cool stuff that this
game does really at all so let's
highlight some of that um i figured this
is a really good place to start this is
my second playthrough
playing on english this time around and
i am about halfway through act
two and this is a main quest that i have
already started
um and i know this is really simple if
you've played it you'll already know but
i can just
goddamn walk away that's not nobody
that's not my horse whenever i want to
right literally walk away and do
absolutely anything else without getting
a desynchronized without getting a fail
and it has just so many little touches
like that
that i just want to see in open world
games that of course
developers aren't going to put in more
open world games if we don't talk about
how much we enjoy these things so that's
the first one
it's also that when you go to your
quests
uh even in here i can do them out of
order right so like this
is an interesting one of the ishikawa
tale it tells me
exactly how many i have left so it
doesn't just feel like a quest goes on
and on and on and on and on with new
objectives over and over and over again
it's a really smart way to pace things
is that you know exactly how many steps
to this quest with this character you
will have
i think it also does a really good job
just in this menu system
of letting you pick which of these
characters you're most interested in and
having you completely ignore the ones
that you want it doesn't matter
um all of the the massacre tales all of
her stuff i think is
super interesting and i could just jump
through
and do these in different orders right
now obviously
this freaking wind system anyone who's
already played this game will be
exceptionally familiar with this but it
is worth noting i've seen people say
why is it so aggressive why does the
wind gust so hard but it doesn't
sometimes it's just little pieces of
pollen
which means right now on screen there is
no
little mini map there's no waypoint
there is
nothing that is taking me away from just
looking at whatever i want to which
feeds into this open world so well
i could just pick up this quest or i
could follow
that red bird um that you can just kind
of
actually do whatever you want and i feel
like it just makes
like yes this is leading me in a certain
direction but there is no punishment for
if i go off track and i don't have to
reset
anything or look at my mini map again
and get stuck in it if i go off track i
can just choose to go off track
which means that it it feels like even
though open worlds build themselves all
about being about
choice uh or freedom they often aren't
because they also at the same time
beat us over the head with do this to
get this thing this objective will give
you this complete this for this person
um so that you get this xp to do this
and while there is obviously a level
system in this game
and you have all your attributes and
your skills and all that stuff that you
can level up
it actually by taking away some of the
aggressive clause in how scripted
something is
um just literally including this like
pollen flowing design
gives you a reason to explore other than
just
knowing explicitly what the reward is
because it came up on an icon on your
mini-map and
again i would literally be happy to see
every single open
wall game do something more like this i
knew you'd understand
lord sakai i feel like
encounters like that that again i'm
actually not going to proceed i'm going
to say that for later
but it means that that is now you know
in my in my menu i don't have to have
that exact conversation with that guy
when i want to take that quest up again
what are you trying to take me to oh you
were trying to take me here it's to a
tale
you just come across stuff like this
including the wildlife which
is another cool thing i just punched my
microphone
i have not killed any animals in this
game uh aside from a ball
once that you have to for a quest but um
this entire playthrough i haven't killed
a deer i haven't killed a bird
that's obviously like a minor note um
but i feel like it also makes the world
feel like a more pleasant ecosystem that
you can really easily get lost in
more so than again an open world full of
things that are just
objectives things that are just going to
add to a completion list
it feels like it's there for me to like
genuinely
experience rather than
to complete a series of checklists that
a designer clearly put there if that
made sense
um i feel like it's also worth
mentioning literally both of those right
i already had that tail that blue one
that just came up
uh in my menu because a peasant had told
me about it
um and the same kind of applies for the
side quest that i
rejected so as people tell you this
information
the map slowly unlocks the every single
question mark here
will be something that i have in some
way organically heard about and
even someone who's played the exact same
amount of amount of hours as i have up
to this point in this game
won't necessarily have any of these same
checkpoints um but i also really love
the fog of war system
uh it it just does a very good job of
like not overwhelming you with
junk that it wants you to do in that we
don't have the
you know far cry assassin's creed climb
tower to unlock area and then see every
single thing in area it is
it's literally a fog of war for both of
the islands here um
if you zoom out you can see everywhere
that i've been it's just it's a unique
enough approach to an open world
especially because you can fast travel
to any location for the record so like
i can fast travel to any fox den even if
i found it and not completed it but it
is on my map
i guess i have completed most of them
but farmsteads
you can fast travel to your pillars of
honor to your hot springs um
so they also make it so that you can get
across the map
really really quickly too another
particularly cool part of the map
uh is this stuff
where this is a main quest but if i
actually look at the location that it's
at it will show up gold if i have one
new
upgrade that is actually available to me
basically meaning that as i'm exploring
the open world
um i know to maybe go to a certain
location
to get whatever my new upgrade is to get
my new gear rather than it being
stuck in my own menu rather than it
being tied to what xp i have
it is actually a person who has
something available to me i guess there
are also just
very cool things where uh what are we
gonna do techniques here
the exploration is concerned so you can
have the wind take you to the nearest
objective there is a certain kind of
clothing
um i don't know what it is actually but
there is a thing that you can wear where
your controller will vibrate if you are
near a particular item
but obviously all of these are so good
for completionists in an open world
where you can actually buy these um
exploration upgrades that will tell you
where to go for these specific things uh
whatever you're interested in
i feel like there are a lot of games out
there that would have you buy maps
you'd either buy them for a trader or in
this the year 2020
they would actually have you buy them
with micro transactions
uh this is part of an upgrade system
that you can opt into if you're a person
who wants to get a reasonable
collectible
but i feel like just because of the way
this game is designed and i also want to
say i feel like i've seen a lot of other
people say this
it is an open world game that i actually
want to spend a lot of time in because
it isn't constantly telling me
what i'm not doing it isn't constantly
trying to make me get xp
or collectibles it is more of a like
follow the world and discover what you
want at your own pace and we will make
it easier for you if you like or you can
ignore it entirely if you like but we're
not gonna
overwhelm you with it in every location
that you go to i guess there are also
just like a couple of other
i want to say basic things but i'm sure
all of these things add up to be like
little tiny basic pieces that just make
this one really cool picture
um like i do think there is a really
solid amount of wild variety i saw
people calling this game ugly
um around the time that the embargo went
up which just seems crazy to me
because you know where we're going from
an area that was storming back there
which obviously this is a big grassy
field but into this like
beautiful golden tree area and
okay can we i missed it can we talk
about standoffs
the standoff there which i wish i had
done i'm just going to run away from it
because i don't want to do it i don't
have to if i don't want to
i can literally leave and it doesn't
tell me i failed anything
it just lets me leave wow he nearly hit
me but i
i want to say like standoffs i think are
a very cool way to tell you that there
are enemies approaching damn dude
rip bro those are again just another way
that the open wall kind of gives you the
option of engaging or not um
you could also completely ignore the
standoff and engage in combat anyway
but it does mean that you know enemies
are there before they tend to know
you're there meaning
you have the option of deciding if you
want to
get the jump on them or if you want to
completely leave and of course that's
only if you haven't already seen them
with your eyes a couple of other things
i guess
load time uh load times are a big one so
let's just
go we can go here
let's see how long this takes
five six that was six seconds
unless i maybe counted one second wrong
but fought from what i can tell it was
six seconds
that's crazy fast and again open well
game
super important to be able to give you
the option of going wherever you want to
without
bogging you down in a load screen i want
to find a uh
a group of mongols just to show you guys
something but hang on let me
hello horse also worth mentioning
um best horse mechanics in any open
world game i just 100
believe that uh the fact that i can ride
at a tree and horse is smart enough to
not
dive nose first into a tree as a horse
would be smart enough to know it'll move
out of the way on its own
um just kind of seems like a
why did other people not do this uh
yeah for sure the best open world horse
in my opinion all right let's do the
standoff let's do it
i don't have all my upgrades so i don't
think i can chain it unfortunately but
all right let's go
oh i thought he was gonna punch me
so there's one thing i wanted to show
you guys with the combat specifically
but maybe this group won't be
big enough um
[Music]
i wish there was a camera for a combat i
really do i wish there was a lot of
cameras
yeah i don't think this game is perfect
for the record i just think it does a
lot of really good
open world stuff i do have other videos
where i've spoken about you know some of
my issues with it um
anime ai was a thing that i didn't love
this guy's running away where are you
going boss
uh but yes the weather will change on
how you fight um it was hard for me to
pay attention during this fight because
obviously i'm trying to fight people
but if you play as a ghost or if you
play super aggressive the weather will
literally change
to match your mood supposedly there are
literally more storms in the game
based on how much ghost type of stuff
you do
thank you my god you should avoid the
swamps
settlement the mongols there you go
strategic location
that interaction is going to give me
probably something new on my map because
she
organically told me where something is i
don't have much of a choice
it's just it's a so much better approach
a so much more rewarding approach
than climbing a tower or something and
having everything
be unlocked see it like literally says
map updated i absolutely love that
but of course you can also play the
flute to literally change
the weather uh to what you like um and
obviously that's not even talking about
the photo mode which is this game is
so photogenic and photo mode is just
so easy to get into and you can
absolutely change everything
the time of day color grading how much
exposure there is
the one other thing that uh will mention
in his thread is that you can call out
the lost enemy in any of the
camps so if you go to a camp and you
want to break into it
and there's only one enemy remaining you
don't have to go and find them you can
literally call them out and have them
come to you and it also i feel like fits
with the game narratively that jyn would
do that i also love there's no stamina
there's no stamina
for the horse either i don't have to
worry about that when i'm exploring
uh gin can jump off most heights with
one um upgrade that you can get pretty
early on you just have to roll when you
land which i guess makes it a mechanic
so there's
there is fall damage to the extent that
you can't really jump off something that
would be
you know absurdly tall but more than you
should realistically
be able to for sure also love this
you can just jump on your horse while
already sprinting and you never have to
stop
i feel like there's so much that i could
list about just like how i really like
this open world uh
i love that when you're talking to a
character they will ride at the same
speed as you will walk at the same speed
as you and you
can just hold forward and even if they
make a turn you will just turn with them
games have been so bad at that for so
long because tsushima basically fixes
that problem the open world i think is
just
really underrated for a lot of the the
little things that it does
um for just how genuinely
fun it is to explore how much it
minimizes that that feeling of
open well being a chore um and i feel
like if we get more stuff like this that
whole like oh look at that that whole
idea of open world fatigue wouldn't be
so much of a problem because it's not
necessarily that like people are tired
of games being big or long
which to be fair has always seemed like
a really strange thing to me that
publishers or devs always talk up our
game is so long it's the longest biggest
one we've ever made but i don't ever
feel like i see
actual gamers being like i would like a
bigger open world and a longer game very
often
but i think it's probably more than a
lot of open world games started to
follow the exact same sort of formula
and uh this one has a lot of really
unique takes on that formula and i
really just
appreciate it for that so that's it for
me today everyone i am gonna finish this
shrine
i hope you all enjoyed this frankly
probably pretty unstructured video i
just felt like i had a lot of things
that i wanted to get through
i will see you all next time
[Music]